hey guys what's up it is the day after
the Big Apple event yesterday where they
announced the new iPhone 7 new Apple
watch Series 2 and air pods and
something that they failed to mention
was anything about iPad updates but this
is kind of huge news they dropped the
price of the iPad pro and they also
doubled the storage in most of the lower
end devices so it's not something that
you think you might want to mention I'm
not sure the pros higher storage tears
receiving a price cut by $100 which
they've been pushing that iPad pro to
replace your PCs for quite a while which
I don't feel like for me personally it
will ever be a PC replacement because I
do way too many things that that iPad
pro will not be able to handle but for
most consumers most regular people who
are not doing anything crazy photo
sharing email Twitter Instagram you
could possibly use it as a replacement
to your computer to your laptop to your
desktop I'm still surprised they didn't
make any mention of this maybe they ran
out of time maybe CEO was like yo what's
up I gotta do a couple extra songs which
I actually didn't finish watching the
SIA event the iPad lineup mysteriously
and silently has in fact changed quite a
bit this is our press announcement and
they didn't even announce anything about
the iPad is this supposed to be a secret
with an accident is not something did
you meant to do Apple or not sure so
Apple has doubled its storage and all
the iPads Mini air and pro and in doing
so without raising prices so we
appreciate that Apple the 16 gigabyte
iPad models are now gone which is crazy
especially for an iPad that is not much
space at all they now start at 32 gigs
and in 64 versions are also gone there
now 128 is the mid tier here's a new
lineup what do you guys think are you
still I pad fans do you use your iPad do
you have an iPad you have a tablet I
also saw this too it's a $40 dongle that
lets you use your wired headphones and
charge your iPhone 7 so this is
something that people have been
extremely worried about so with the
removal yesterday of the 3.5 millimeter
jack which is kind of crazy because I
had ordered on Amazon Prime now an
auxilary cable for my car same day and
it was just sitting there in the kitchen
I was like what have I done this is talk
about irony we knew it was coming the
rumors fanned out to be true with this
it looks like you'll be able to charge
your phone and
music at the same time which has been
most people's biggest concerns this is a
cool little article two years later
Apple has finally figured out what the
watch is good for the only new feature
this isn't specifically geared towards
improvement of fitness tracking is the
faster processor oh yeah
no kidding and that's what most people
want in a wearable watch is fitness
tracking they want to know their heart
rates they want to know their steps they
want to know the calories burned and now
with the integration of Pokemon go I'm
going to be walking a lot more you have
promised you that there's some hands-on
photos that looks like Engadget got from
the press event so let's take a little
peek at these these look really nice
yeah by one God the ceramic look at this
man this looks good so that was really
the biggest news I just want to get your
guys thoughts on what you think of this
is this some sort of crazy conspiracy
probably not I don't know why they
wouldn't have mentioned it it's kind of
strange at least like a simple subtle
mention now this office on MacRumors
where they were doing some performance
tests with the a10 chip that is in the
new iPhone 7 and outperforms all
existing iOS devices which is kind of
crazy because here's the iPad pro but
the a10 fusion built in the iPhone 7 is
a four core processor with two high
power cores for handling system
intensive tasks and two high efficiency
cores that kick in for less intensive
processes to save battery
hopefully that simple little integration
will help us save battery because I use
my phone way too much the guys had seen
the unboxing that I did of all the
no-fee devices those are used on a daily
basis
not only for my phone but for GoPros and
everything and one of the biggest
struggles for everyone is battery life
let's all have that for you guys today I
got a new microphone so I'm excited let
me know what you think of it does it
sound better
does it sound worse it definitely cannot
sound worse if it sounds worse than you
guys are crazy
I have so much trouble in his office
with acoustics he's super echoey
I need to figure out a solution that
will still look good because I love the
white aesthetic but I've I've come quite
accustomed ooh I definitely don't want
to have crazy big panels hanging off the
wall I still want them to look good so
the struggle is real I'll see you guys
later
I felt like I wanted to tell you
something else I think today I supposed
to have a cooking video out but I didn't
edit it yet so we'll see if it actually
gets posted as you guys later
I'm getting real rowdy so the whole
livestream starts off of Tim Cook and
James Corden in a car doing the whole
carpool karaoke thing James is driving
him around San Francisco